[Music]
i get lots of comments and questions see
if game of thrones prequel series is
cancelled
people say they are reading about it all
over the internet the answer is yes
one game of thrones prequel is cancelled
its name was the long knight or the
blood moon
but the other game of thrones prequel
series house of the dragon about which
i've been talking about on this channel
is not
the game of thrones prequel series house
of the dragon is in the process of
filming
and will be released early on in 2022 or
in other words in just over one year
unlike the long night prequel hbo
ordered
the entire first season of house of the
dragon meaning that this prequel cannot
be cancelled
hbo's prequel blood moon was meant to
fill the gap that game of thrones left
behind
but a project has been cancelled and
replaced with house of the dragon
if the long night prequel was not
cancelled it would already be out as
2020 was its official release date
blood moon was supposed to be about the
long night at first it seemed as if
everything was going just fine with it
and hbo even filmed the pilot
but for whatever reason chose not to
turn it into a series
a pilot episode was written and produced
by jane goldman
said thousands of years before game of
thrones hours after announcing that the
blood moon prequel was cancelled
hbo announced that they ordered the
entire first season of house of the
dragon
pilots sometimes they come together
sometimes they don't
hbo's president casey blois told variety
about why the network decided to go with
one prequel series over the other
and i would say that was very much the
case here there's nothing i would point
to and say oh this was the problem
however bloise did reveal that since
house of the dragon is based on martin's
writing
it was easier for the show's creative
team to delve into the story of house
targaryen
that prequel was 8 000 years before the
current show
so it required a lot more invention he
explained one of the benefits of house
of the dragon is there was a text from
george
and there was a little bit more of a
roadmap set more than 5000 years before
game of thrones
the cancelled show blood moon was not
planning to feature any of the game of
thrones characters we already know and
love
as a matter of fact some of the houses
and families did not even exist in this
time period
like targaryens for example according to
hbo's official synopsis the blood moon
was meant to tell the story of the
world's descent
from the golden age of heroes into its
darkest hour
it planned to center around the children
of the forest and how they created the
first white walker we now know as the
night king
a teaser for the series said it will
reveal the horrifying secrets of
westeros history
to the true origin of the white walkers
the age of heroes is the name given to
the period in time
which saw the first men and the children
of the forest come together to agree on
a piece pact
this happened around 10 000 years before
the first game of thrones episode is set
it ended around 7 000 years later with
the coming of the andals
the exact time the age of heroes ended
is not clear
as different sources in westeros gave
different accounts
this meant that the fans would not know
for sure when the blood moon was set
the only details confirmed were that
it's the age of hero zera
casey blow is the president of hbo
programming told deadline
one of the things i think jane took on
beautifully which was a challenge
there was a lot more world creation
because she set hers
8 000 years before the original show so
it required a lot more
he added we would have been very lucky
to do one pilot
have that pilot go and be a success but
in development as you know it takes a
lot of tries to get it right
this is no different in an interview
with entertainment weekly the creator
george r martin stated that blood moon
prequel
was supposed to be set roughly 5 000
years before the events of the game of
thrones
we are dealing with a different and
older world martin told the
entertainment weekly
in the interview georgia or martin also
said westeros is a very different place
king's landing will not even exist yet
and as a result there is no iron throne
either
meanwhile valyria will have hardly begun
to rise martin explained
it's not the story we think we know it
will teach us more about westeros
history
the white walker's origins and the
mysteries of the east
in his interview with the new york times
martin stressed that the long night
prequel was mostly the creation of jane
goldman
in his own words if you look at the
published books so far
there's really very little material
about the age of heroes and the long
night
a sentence here a sentence there old nan
tells a tale that takes up a paragraph
so jane had to create the characters the
settings and some of the events
and we had to look at everything that
was said and say okay here's what was
said at this point
we need to make it consistent to that we
kicked around some ideas and i made some
suggestions
but mostly it's been jane running with
it martin therefore explained that he
did not create the plot outline
characters or setting details for the
long night tv series
it was announced by hbo on october 29th
that plans to produce the long night
spin-off had been scrapped
after viewing the pilot hbo was not
thrilled by the results
and even gave showrunner jane goldman
and her team notes on change as needed
but even after the re-edit of the pilot
hbo was still not thrilled and decided
not to green light
the pilot to series hours after the
cancellation that same day
hbo greenlighted instead another game of
thrones prequel direct to sirius
that's co-created by george r martin and
ryan condole
kondo will be a co-show runner with
famous game of thrones director miguel
sapochnick
who will also work on the pilot and
additional episodes in the prequel
series called house of the dragons
house of the dragon will draw from
georgia or martin's novel fire and blood
which reveals more about the history of
the targaryens
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as showrunners and executive
producers
george r martin will also serve as
executive producer
it's based on georgia martin's book fire
and blood volume 1
and on mars yet unfinished fire and
blood vol 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary aegon the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
that's fire and blood vol 1. the atana
released fire and blood volume 2 will
continue from where part 1
ended with rhaenyra targaryen's son
aegon iii
reign and will cover blackfyre
rebellions the war with dorne and go all
the way to the mad king
and robert's rebellion that attended
targaryen dynasty
some would think that you could just
read the book fire and blood to know
what will happen in the show
based on that very same book but that's
far from truth
why because firing blood is not a
non-conventional novel
it's imaginary history book and
according to george armard himself
not very accurate to that because
wildfire and blood book was written by
george r martin
it wasn't written from him as facts but
rather through the perspective of the
citadel's archmaester gildane
who gathered all the info and as many
different sources as he could and used
it to write the book about the targaryen
history
some info is fake some info is true some
info is semi true
no one will know for a fact what was
happening in the real history
until the house of the dragon airs in
this is this book's not actually written
by me you see it's written by
archmaester gildane of the citadel
and he's writing a history and like
anyone writing history he has to go back
to primary sources
and i had a lot of fun with that because
when he gets to the dance of dragons he
has a number of primary sources but
three of them are most major he has he
has grand master orwell's official court
records
he has the septon who was
kept the the sept in in king's landing
and the red keep
who of course is a is a religious figure
so he interprets everything
as the will of the gods and what was a
sin and what wasn't the same
and he has mushroom who was
semi-illiterate and
couldn't actually write anything but who
told his story um
in later years to a to a equivalent of a
monk who wrote it all down
i i love the idea since this was a fake
history i didn't want to
tell it as an omniscient historian
setting down this is what actually
happened i love the idea of
telling it as a historian in world who's
trying to figure out what happened but
he's looking better as primary sources
and he's finding contradictory accounts
the show
unlike the book will contain truth it
will depict what actually happened
not the change history fake or semi-true
not what might or might not have
happened
the key event of house of the dragon
will be the targaryen civil war
the dance of the dragons the dance of
the dragons was the most devastating war
in the history of the seven kingdoms
the war of succession between aegon ii
and his half-sister rhaenyra over their
father viserys the first throne
both of them thought they belonged on
the iron throne when people started
declaring for one of them or the other
their fight divided the kingdoms in two
targaryens fought targaryens
brothers fought brothers dragons fought
the dragons
by the time it was over thousands were
dead the conflict would prove to be
incredibly destructive for not only
house targaryen
but large parts of westeros as well
additionally devastated the targaryen's
dragon population
ultimately leading to their extinction
within a few decades
they never truly recovered by the end of
the reign of king viserys first
targaryen 20 dragons were alive
the majority of these died during the
civil war called the dance of the
dragons
which began in 129 ac and lasted until
mid 131 ac
dozens of major battles even more
smaller battles
and even more betrayals turn cloaks and
twists all of that this game of thrones
pretty cool show house of the dragon
brings in 2022
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace